Do you ever anticipate a problem like with guys that are supposed to be fighting
each other?
You know,
like what just happened with Mazda doll recently?
Like we're an actual fist fight breaks out,
man,
you find most of these guys wanna get paid to fight,
not pay the fight.
Right.
But when you see like cameras are on,
they're not.
So yeah,
that fight with w yeah,
that's true.
Right.
When the cameras aren't on.
The other thing is when you're leading into a fight,
my thought was you cannot let that person think the intimidated you.
And if that means you actually have to hit them,
maybe it does.
But the,
the,
you know the ideas that I can't let you think that you have a mental advantage,
right.
In any other sports.
So we know why I ever want to see that.
Like,
dude,
it's just like you gotta stop that.
But in fighting it's like,
oh,
they're just doing extra fighting.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
I was like,
you guys are getting paid.
Yeah.
Look it was a basketball player,
sucker punches another basketball player in the face and some sort of press
conference like that,
like Mazda doll did.
I mean,
you'd be like,
what?
No Way.
But in fighting like,
oh,
these are the extra fighting,
but you don't,
you don't connect for buddy or extra credit for do.
But let's be honest,
people like to offer that performance was going to get extra money.
Just stunning knock out of Darren tills,
one of the top guys in the welterweight division,
the weight Kao.
Then it was crazy.
So he got it from that.
And then to tee off on Leon Edwards after the fight like that,
it's like another one,
like that's part of that is very good for him,
unfortunately.
Like I don't want him to do that and I,
I don't wanna encourage,
but if you want to think about like a fighter's popularity building,
their brand brown,
he's an,
I don't give a fuck,
I'll punch you in the face guy.
And they're like,
well,
a lot of people are now.
He's a real,
I don't give a fuck.
I'll punch you in your face guy.
They're real.
They're really exist.
And he's a world class fighter.
Like that's a,
that's sellable.
It's unfortunate.
I wish guys wouldn't ever fight at press conference.
It's like Cormier and Jon Jones.
I fucking hated that.
But tell me that didn't sell more tickets.
No doubt.
That's sold a shitload more tickets.
How many times they throw out,
show Connor thrown that Dolly.
How many times they show that even in the Promos,
I hated when that happened.
There was a terrible thing that Conner did that Goddamn,
that's sold some tickets.
That's a,
that's a fine line.
Right?
That's kind of a funny thing.
People that weren't even involved got cut.
You got hit with glass.
It's got canceled on me that,
I mean,
using it promoted.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
We just tried to avoid it and hide it.
Or do we let people know that this is a real thing?
They call all,
all people involved.
Go,
look,
this is a business.
We're here to get paid.
Okay,
we're gonna run it.
We're gonna run it every 15 minutes.
I'm going to show that Dolly Smash.
Oh,
and that's we'll Harris's company.
Is that the,
the the gentleman,
what is it?
What is it called and not to me of a fighter.
Yes.
That's his youtube show that I often thought was a UFC show.
I didn't even know that he had his own show.